[Música]
oyentes o cyber seguidores de radio
canadá internacional bienvenidos a su
programa semanal semanal canadá en las
américas café o el castor cibernético
los saluda paloma martínez desde los
estudios de radio canadá internacional
aquí en montreal el menú de la semana es
materno y nómada materno porque es el
día de las madres en todo el mundo esta
semana y nómada porque tenemos un poco
la oportunidad de conversar con un
viajero con causa
jimmy hunger aquí en el estudio está en
leonora chapman rufo valència leonardo
gimeno saludo a todos nuestros oyentes y
ciber seguidores por facebook live como
cada semana les hablaremos de algunas
noticias entrevistas reportajes y
leeremos algunas de sus cartas
comenzamos con el nova nomadismo de
jimmy 1 después de haber recorrido las
américas en moto en 2015 viajando por 11
meses a través de 18 países
jimmy un publicó su libro americano
donde presentó 150 entrevistas
fotográficas con gente que conoció en el
camino organizó dos muestras de fotos
varias conferencias y talleres en
escuelas secundarias de la agencia de
naciones unidas para la educación y la
cultura la unesco y esto fue en canadá
en francia en noruega senegal
promoviendo el concepto de la ciudadanía
mundial y el diálogo intercultural está
ahora en buenos aires- mes de mayo y se
encuentra en el museo de arte
latinoamericano de esa ciudad como está
allí myung muy bien muy bien muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros hoy por
vía skype está usted lejísimos pero
parece que está aquí con nosotros y sí
gracias por recibirme un paseo cuéntanos
un poco sobre este museo de arte
latinoamericano en buenos aires-
cuéntanos brevemente de qué se trata
este museo
si el mal va en buenos aires es un museo
dedicado a los dos artistas de américa
latina y entonces para mí es un lugar
muy importante porque cuando yo vengo
acá a probar obras de todo el continente
aunque falta uno de canadá
yo creo siempre que los dos franceses
hablantes son latinos también entonces
el único que falta es la única pero
falta la otra parte de las américas las
partes del norte de las américas
entonces a mí me sorprendió aquí en
canadá en la diferenciación entre dicen
las tres américas no es américa como el
continente completo es américa el norte
central y del sur
entonces dividen y eso también esa
división a veces a veces pega no pero
nuestro programa siempre estamos
hablando de la unión de las américas
áfrica nada en las américas somos parte
de las américas
y aunque justamente lo que señala pues
quizá lo que se pierde a veces de vista
es que es el único continente que va de
norte a sur
y no hay no no es como por ejemplo
australiano que hace parte de la mácula
pero es una isla pero en cambio el
américa que además tiene un solo nombre
abya yala desde el sur ya que llama la
gran tortuga
entonces habría tiene razón había que
ver porque si son las américas porque en
base a que son las américas
uno dice las europas
como tendríamos que decir que américa
también tiene otra connotación que son
los eeuu
ese es un problema yo creo de definición
también porque se apropiaron es que
cuando uno escucha los discursos dicen
américa entonces ese es quedó eso se
apropiaron un poco de ese palabras de lo
que significa entonces a lo mejor por
eso también uno hace las diferencias es
un tema político en mi en tu viaje notas
de esta diferencia de las américas o es
una sola américa la que recorre este
para mí cuando viaje la idea era de
buscar lo que tenemos en común a través
de todo el continente por eso que para
mí también hay un continente américa y
cuando yo escucho las américas no pienso
en el norte es entre el centro había sur
pienso más nadie así la cultura o
quieres ver a quien en las américas hay
bastante perspectivas culturas y yo
eligió de verlo así pero es un trabajo
siempre particularmente del norte del
norte del continente de desarrollar este
sentido de conexión con el de la
historia continente pero por eso y
pernando
por eso que estoy acá intentando siempre
de hacer conexiones entre la punta del
norte que canadá que es mi país y acá en
la sentía que está esa punta desde el
sur y la idea de cuando juntamos las
culturas entre los dos países juntamos
también el continentes
estás haciendo en argentina a jimmy
porque ya recorriste en muchos países
ahora estás en argentina específicamente
haciendo qué
bueno por un lado
vengo acá para la cultura hay varios
eventos que estoy acá para para ver y
también además hay una historia de amor
parecida
no son las mujeres argentinas una de las
más lindas de américa esta tarjeta roja
si lo contrario no puede decir lo
contrario lo que siente es que su
relación con américa latina no es
reciente hace muchos años que tiene ya
una relación con la con las américas
digamos con américa latina uno de sus
primeros contactos fue una película que
todos conocemos diarios de motocicleta
sobre el primer viaje del che guevara
por las américas y hace unos días
justamente usted me contaba que tuvo la
oportunidad de conocer a carlos calica
ferrer que fue quien viajó con el che
pero en el segundo viaje que no se hizo
por motocicleta pero igual fue para
usted es importante me decía si usted
del libro y por eso
compartiendo este nuevo libro y tuve la
oportunidad de encontrarlo y fue
realmente muy significativo para mí
porque el viaje de elche moto fue lo que
me inspiró hacia mi propio viaje en moto
y si por casualidad lo encontré acá en
buenos aires en un intento y cuando
escuché sus historias sobre sus viajes
con elche y la idea de buscar conocer
más la cultura y entender mejor el
contexto social de américa latina sentí
realmente que había una conexión entre
mi proyecto y el suyo
es que la fotografía llegó antes que la
motocicleta o después o durante el viaje
durante el tiempo la idea fue hacer las
fotos desde antes de salir de acá ya
tenía como idea empezar a hacer un común
o una documentación del viaje por foto
cierto sí sí la idea
me llegó a unas semanas antes la verdad
yo quería buscar una manera de compartir
mi experiencia y antes pensaba hacer un
blog pero la idea del blog que yo no
quería compartir mi lista sería
compartida de vista de la gente que
conocí en el viaje y por eso que te
invito a la gente que conocía a sacar
fotos ellos mismos y de compartir
conmigo sus historias y de eso fue la
idea si me interesa también el tema
jimmy de es escuchando desde que también
cuando viajaba si vas a escuelas
asistidas a escuelas era para presentar
tus fotografías tu visión del recorrido
que estabas haciendo en américa o había
también otros objetivos sí bueno yo por
mucho tiempo con los jóvenes entonces
siempre creo que el futuro está en los
jóvenes y que la educación es la clave
para todo y por eso que es una cosa de
vídeo el ya que yo mismo
creo que eso está en un privilegio que
hay que compartir esta experiencia con
la gente que aquí a veces no tiene la
oportunidad de viajar así y gracias a la
fotografía gracias a la computadora
un proyector pero compartir mis
historias las historias la gente que
conocí en el viaje y yo creo que es con
nuestras historias muy sencillas que
podemos desarrollar una conexión
emocional también porque de las noticias
escuchamos siempre la mala noticia sobre
cosas políticas y lo que falta es las
historias humanas y eso es lo que se
obtuviesen por tan interesante y me
dijiste también que siempre trabajo
trabajaste mucho con jóvenes a dónde fue
eso y qué tipo de trabajo hacías fue en
canadá
sí bueno mucho en canadá de trabajo
antes de viajar por ejemplo trabajé con
la comisión canadiense para la unesco y
estaba encargado de un redes de escuelas
solares de canadá que trabajan con la
unesco para desarrollar la paz y la
convivencia y antes también a través de
curar una ong que se llama uni
y es una organización que trabajan en
países en desarrollo pero también en
escuelas en canadá para ayudar a la
gente los jóvenes a empoderarse para
mejor entender los desafíos del mundo y
también para para apoyar a los jóvenes
en otros países y de hecho me parece que
el año pasado en el 2017 este trabajo
que usted venía haciendo con la comisión
de la unesco en canadá y el viaje por
américa latina en la motocicleta se
juntaron de alguna forma porque decidió
viajar en motocicleta de nuevo a través
del territorio canadiense un poco
repitiendo la experiencia de las
américas
pero no hizo las 150 entrevistas hizo un
poco menos cierto sí la verdad que me di
cuenta de que viaje más por otros países
que mi propio país en moto entonces en
el año pasado empezó un viaje récord y
por cuatro provincias fue también en una
voz y después tuve un accidente en el
norte de quebec y tenía que parar por un
momento entonces tengo 50 entrevista
ahora y está esperándole seguida
estoy dando y para compartir las
historias también de los canadienses a
través de décadas tendrá próximos
proyectos relacionados con este viaje en
canadá también ya mí
si estoy preparando también un otro
libro que ahora además no es de
fotografía pero para más de mis
pensamientos personales porque bueno
tuve la oportunidad de viajar por más de
35 países y siempre cuando yo viajo yo
voy para hablar con la gente que te
encuentro lo que me interesa es la
cultura la identidad y entonces estoy
preparando un libro sobre la identidad
mundial y también sobre el contexto del
privilegio porque me doy me doy cuenta
siempre que eso es viajar así es manejar
un gran privilegio y se tiene con la
responsabilidad y quiero como
desarrollar más ese punto de vista
pregunta en qué idioma el libro
yo quería preguntarle también jimmy con
respecto a sus orígenes porque usted
nació aquí en canadá pero sus padres son
de origen camboyano y chino me parece
también no solamente camboyanos si mi
bisabuelo se fueron de china hacia
camboya y de camboya mí para mí me
parece que fuera un gran después de la
guerra en los años setentas y vivieron
dos años en los campos de refugiados en
tailandia y después tuvieron la
oportunidad de venir a canadá en
montreal y yo nací afortunadamente en
montreal entonces personalmente no
conocí la guerra pero crecí con todas
las historias de mi padres y esto
realmente desarrolló mi sensibilidad por
las gestiones de justicia social y de la
conexión qué cara tienes cuando los
países en desarrollo y por eso que para
mí américa latina
también tiene muchos países en
desarrollo y pero fue una manera más
cerca para mí
tocar estos temas jimmy home ha sido un
gran gusto conversar con el exterior y
ahora última pregunta que se me está
ocurriendo que me parece bueno unos
dicen que cuando uno hace este tipo de
viajes siendo joven es la visión de uno
mismo cambia la suya y respecto al mundo
en el que vive me pregunto jimmy si
cuando regresas a canadá tienes una
visión tal vez se cargas elementos
culturales que traes de otros lados y
que te hacen ver tal vez diferente a la
sociedad canadiense a la que la dejaste
si obviamente pero creo que es cuánto de
estas diferencias con él con esta
experiencia directa que se pueden ver lo
que hay en común porque si no no si no
tienes experiencia de la diferencia es
más difícil de realmente entender lo que
hay en común y por el viaje y si quiero
dejarlos con una palabra
ernesto guevara se siente me inspiró
para mis viajes que deja que el mundo te
cambie y podrás cambiar interesante una
pregunta bueno por la primera es
finalmente y después de todas estas
experiencias porque viajar también es
ese es conectarse con la conozco con las
costumbres de la gente hoy tú qué
prefieres un churrasco un putin
esto es lo que falta es una rutina al
sabor de alturas
bueno cuando vuelvas a montreal
serás invitado con un asado y
acompañamiento putin así hacemos para la
gente que nos está escuchando en américa
latina no tiene nada que ver con el
presidente de rusia sino que putin una
comida típica quebequense hecha con
papas fritas y una salsa
igual que su gusto maravilloso seguro
seguro rico bueno combinada con
churrasco
bueno organicemos eso jimmy muchas
gracias y me van desde hay buenos aires
gracias por comunicarse con nosotros hoy
por él por aceptar esta entrevista para
canadá en las américas café es un salve
resentencias saludos a todos hasta luego
entonces vamos pausa y volvemos con más
cosas aquí en canadá en las américas
café
y
[Música]
estoy en crisis de capel y el nuevo from
switch una provincia al este de cadera y
los sentidos escuchar canadá en las
américas casi el programa de radio
canadá internacional en la web esta
semana hubo varias noticias importantes
unas difíciles como los misiles en siria
desde israel o el temor de los
científicos sobre la extinción de osos y
pingüinos para el 2100 hubo varias
noticias que seguramente llamaron la
atención de aquí de mis colegas durante
la semana algo que quieran resaltar
sobre lo que sucedió esta semana
yo encontré me encuentro un preocupante
esa es un panel de investigadores e
internacionales que se están
investigando continuamente el tema del
recalentamiento de las aguas de los
océanos y simplemente en cada vez se
muestran menos optimistas respecto a lo
que va a pasar en un futuro no muy
lejano están hablando del 2
100 y lo que ellos ponen sobre la mesa
es el tema de la desaparición de
especies para esa época y están hablando
ya concretamente con los osos polares
aquí en el ártico canadiense y el bonito
de la parte del ártico y los pingüinos
no que ese es uno de estos pingüinos y
no puede creer que van a desaparecer
entonces es muy preocupante ese es un
tema que a mí me parece que pues va a
estar continuamente sobre la mesa la
seriedad por miles de años más no es
preocupante y además a pesar lo que lo
encuentro difícil es que ellos dicen que
a pesar de los esfuerzos que se están
haciendo para combatir el
recalentamiento la disminución de la
capa de ozono como está afectando
también justamente a las aguas de los
océanos es muy no hay muchas
posibilidades tal vez de que eso cambie
de manera pues grande no entonces esos
miedos creo que se van a concretizar en
el 2100 y por esos años
trufa
lo que me llama la atención y yo diría
que una noticia que realmente pasó
totalmente desapercibida y quizá tiene
quizá aquí reveló un poco más sobre mí
no sólo en lo personal es que murió en
bolivia el último dictador luis garcía
meza y a los ochenta y pico años y quizá
fue y murió bajo detención estaba
detenido así que digamos que el último
dictador del siglo 20 en bolivia ha
muerto y eso me lo dijo recién ayer un
amigo y no podía creer que quique y
trabajamos en medios y se me escapó eso
se nos escapan muchas cosas
desgraciadamente porque hay mucho que
está sucediendo en todos lados sí y es
una y otro y otro detalle interesante es
justamente un mensaje que le dieron al
presidente de donald trump a quien los
medios lo consideran errático los medios
y mucho más en eeuu y es en lo que una
persona le dice por televisión
que donald sé que no crees los cambios
climáticos pero se te viene una gran
storm una gran tercera edad
y quien dice eso es la crisis esto
permite años y ramas de televisión que
lo más interesante es el del sábado the
night live' la noche del sábado en vivo
un programa humorístico pero que
irónicamente en américa del norte el
humor se ha convertido en la herramienta
más eficaz de descenso político leonardo
alguna cosa que destacar yo te puse a
trabajar un poco así último minutos y si
no lo que me llama la atención es la
euforia por el mundial que se viene el
único aunque no hay tanta euforia como
otros años no sé si es el frío de rusia
así es la cara de putin y no sé no sé
realmente no sé o sigo pensando que es
porque está lejos pero yo creo que eso
se va a recuperar
el pitazo del partido
pero en el mundial 2014 en brasil
además es américa latina pero había en
la gente en las calles de montreal los
autos con banderines de todos los países
y hoy no lo es
el verano no ha llegado el calor no ha
llegado yo tengo fotos de esta misma
época en otros años y ya estaban mis
plantas sembradas y creciendo en esta
época mucho frío quiero saludar a la
gente que nos está viendo que tenemos
conoces al palacio y está con nosotros
ismael zamora dice acá en méxico frente
de la madre fue ayer
creo que fue ayer de kelvin franklin
saludos desde lima perú nos dice que el
vino franklin después tenemos a ismael
zamora abrazo para todas las mamás verse
y así cantar también es mamá sí señor
cardona y saludos de san luis potosí
méxico javier gonzález en un garage y
tengo la oportunidad de verlos en
directo saludos a leonora y por favor me
saludan a pablo que está paseando por su
tierra colombiana así que el grande
pablo después saludamos gaby gabi
también dice saludar
así que mandamos saludos y que jesús
cardona dice felices adelantadas a las
madres en canadá que allá se celebra
mañana el domingo es en realidad en
méxico se celebró como siempre el jueves
10 o sea el 10 de mayo y por porque el
10 de mayo porque es una fecha que
siempre se ha establecido no quisieron
entrar en el juego de los domingos yo
cuando cayera era el día de feriado no
no es feriado del día mismo yo ayer con
mi mamá festeje pero está aquí
es como que uno cumpleaños del jueves y
porque el jueves no lo festeja
cuando se pueda
no quiere intentar hacer todo lo posible
por festejar con nosotros siempre
hacemos conocemos las reuniones con mis
hijos el día de cumpleaños cae por
ejemplo durante la semana festejamos el
día festejamos el fin de semana con la
familia después otra reunión con los
amigos y así sucesivamente hay que
perderla las ganas de seguir festejando
no no para nada bueno yo creo que quiero
que nos presenten ahora algunos de los
temas que ustedes privilegian que
quieren que vean que la gente conozca un
poco más en profundidad de lo que
estuvieron trabajando esta semana
leonora tú nos presentas a una médica
tiene canadiense es una médica
canadiense que llegó no hace mucho
tiempo hace cuatro años y eso me llama
un poco la atención su su trayecto
fluido su trayectoria acá porque ella ya
es era médica cirujana en perú
y llegó a canadá pues por cuestiones de
familia no me dijo si era el amor o no
eso no le pregunté hay un poco de amor
en eso sin migraciones pero lo que sí
pues ella le pregunté si sabía si ella
es antes que nada sabía que llegando acá
no iba a poder ejercer clima médica
cirujana era hoy me dijo que sí y que y
que a pesar de eso pues decidió dar el
gran paso y lo que me llamó la atención
es cómo se fue moviendo en la sociedad
es decir empezó por las lenguas tenía un
poco de inglés está estudiando francés
está hablando francés pero además de eso
decidió trabajar y meterse como decimos
nosotros en el voluntariado en un
laboratorio del envejecimiento de la
universidad mcgill bueno ella es médica
no eso al laboratorio imagine también le
conviene tener a una médica que está en
ese momento voluntaria y ella decidió
dar ese paso ayudando a los médicos de
ese laboratorio porque además logró el
hecho interesante que ella dice
es que hay gente pacientes de la
comunidad latinoamericana que a veces
van y no se expresan muy bien sobre todo
gente de edad que no se expresan lo en
inglés o en francés entonces eso es una
ayuda muy 2 a la que ella está dando a
este instituto pues que ella es un poco
la que toma las hace las entrevistas
entonces les explica a los médicos
exactamente los síntomas entonces estás
haciendo un trabajo interesante pero
además de eso ella se hizo un
certificado o en investigación clínica
ahora fue aceptada para hacer una
maestría en neurociencias de la
universidad mcgill o sea está haciendo
muy bien la cosa y su objetivo final es
pasarle el examen en el famoso colegio
de médicos de canadá para ejercer como
médica tal vez ya no cirujana pero es la
para en otra en otra área entonces le
pregunté también cómo era el tema del
colegio de médicos y that down down las
respuestas bastante interesantes sobre
todo sabiendo que acá hay médicos que
llegan y que no pueden ejercer y creo
que el recorrido que ella está haciendo
sirve como para abrir ventanitas en el
sector de las
incluso se habla de la administración en
el sector de la salud hay médicos
inmigrantes no sólo de américa latina de
otros países que están incorporándose a
la administración en estos centros y que
en algún momento pues van a llegar a
otros lugares pero siempre dentro del
área de la medicina entonces sobre todo
si es me silencio muy interesante dar su
ejemplo claro entonces ella es
interesante también las respuestas que
da sobre cómo hacer ese camino más
fácilmente como se llama tienes razón se
llama kilikis quispe
ya que el xp alaya es de perú muy bien
muchas gracias leonora rufo si nos
presentas algo relacionado con eso
es una indígena de libertad de prensa
tuvo un pequeño mensaje que no está no
va no aparece en facebook pero disney
tengo amigos que están siguiendo esto
dice jenny mensing airline
animated la animadora se ve tan animada
la idea es la de animar
y yo pues tuve la ocasión de conocer a
conversar con una indígena kakchiquel
normas han sido y ella participó aquí en
montreal en la orilla de quebec que en
una discusión sobre mujeres y la
seguridad en el periodismo estaba con
otras mujeres canadienses
argelia sobre el activismo digital y
medios alternativos jessica leblanc que
trabaje en un mc de periodista isabel
guiño nfr aunque también estuvo
inclusive trabajando aquí un momento
dado y era como veía en ellas el tema de
las de ser periodistas mujeres y la
seguridad surgió con mujeres entonces en
el ejercicio del beneficio de sus
funciones entonces para las canadienses
lo que destacan es justamente como no
tienen su espacio como en desde las las
crónicas que les dan las áreas que les
dan a cubrir y que un y que se nota
siempre una especie de paternalismo de
quien bueno eres joven y cómo vas a
hacer una entrevista showest vas a
tratar este tema entonces es algo que
inclusive yo lo siento y automáticamente
yo creo que a veces hay ahí como le
llaman tendencias mentales inconscientes
que los ven con respecto a las mujeres
que las mujeres tenemos con respecto a
los hombres entonces probablemente que
eso entra en el línea de juego allá y
ella lo que era destaca es justamente
que nosotros trabajamos aquí con un
libro azul código de normas
periodísticas y ella explicaba y esto
esta entrevista fuese al día de la
libertad de prensa y explicaba que para
ella la libertad de prensa es decir
expresar la verdad con los pies puestos
en su comunidad para lo cual él plantea
pues el principio de los periodismo
latinoamericano que tiene justamente
como base el ser objetivos pero no
indiferentes y que el objetivo central
es el bien común cosa que en las
expresas su verdad
entonces y claro la verdad es cómo
tratar de encontrar el punto centra en
el cosmos no qué es
depende dónde estás si ya parece que hay
una nueva no es nuestro es infinito
tal vez hay un punto central ahora y
entonces ella contaba justamente lo
difícil que es para en guatemala que
aunque ella explicación que en guatemala
hay libertad de prensa' sancionando las
leyes pero que la práctica esto no se
cumple
en la práctica hay libertad de más de
empresa que de prensa y que además es
unos periodistas son mejores o sea hay
de ciertas líneas editoriales que tienen
más masa más difusión y que ayer
explicaba que había perdices que
inclusive fueron asesinados justamente
por poner información que afectaba a
comunidades enteras entonces y sobre
todo con un xerez ya contaba de que
cuando iba a cubrir eventos de que otros
periodistas le cerraban el pas de deux
siento que haces aquí porque tú no eres
periodista porque el indie porque el
indígena y porque además trabajaba en
medios comunitarios
entonces si está en guatemala
en medios comunitarios si es verdad
todos nosotros comenzamos
y hay cierta sintonía con los valores de
la de la radio pública entonces una
conversión muy interesante y que además
pone en perspectiva también la vida
visión de las canadienses periodistas
canadienses muy interesantes normas han
sido las normas en si tengo aquí
mensajes en este caso de diego garcía
dice saludos desde montreal a cuatro
cuadras del edificio de radio canadá
y gaby gabi dice en argentina estamos
esperando que el gobierno nacional saque
un paquete de medidas salvajes contra
los trabajadores eso aplaca las
expectativas para el mundial y eso
también un poco la propia gente está
preocupada puede ser otras cosas pero lo
que llama la atención en este caso
puntual de la argentina es que antes el
fútbol aplacaba todo el resto y
es tan delicada imaginar que argentina
se pierda en primera ronda
a partir de la evidencia me lleva a
tener esas alegrías como decía ese es el
tema o sea creo que tiene tiene bastante
razón en él en el caso bueno de
argentina todo lo decía aquí porque aquí
en el campeonato mundial pasado se vio
una vida especial y ahora bueno no se ve
tanto pero en los países están sufriendo
yo creo que eso también influye en esta
relación con el deporte
xavi justamente hoy día estaba nicolás
se llama nicolás duchovny el ministro
del rol del joven y estaba justamente
pidiendo auxilio al fm y hoy otra vez si
están están justamente estas continuidad
asia lo obtuvieron pero todavía no no no
todavía no saben que el monto ni las
condiciones ni el tema son las
condiciones donde nosotros no lo sabemos
y acondicionado como dicen el [ __ ]
está en los detalles
entonces la en las gomas hay otros hay
otros que dicen que lo que está pasando
en argentina estaba todo bien
planificado no es el azar no es que esto
nation no lo midieron su empresa sino
que está hecho así y con esa con ese
objetivo de llegar a donde se llegó para
ir recurrir al fondo monetario es es
decir no sé si es verdad o no eso es lo
que están diciendo también hay otros que
dicen que se les fue de la mano en la
economía en fin no es lo mismo dirigir
una empresa que dirigir un país no no
pero bueno hay varios ejemplos en
américa la tienen los que se ha tratado
de manejar los países como si fueran
empresas y aquí nos daremos más faltas
esta semana de esta semana digo de
neutralidad de internet en así es porque
bueno como en el 2015
barack obama había
puesto en marcha un plan para la
neutralidad de la red esto significaba
que las grandes empresas no podían ni
aumentar los montos ni privilegiar
contenidos según el precio de lo que la
gente pagaba y en la entrada de la
administración trump esto cambió
presidente de los eeuu decidió que eso
no era correcto así que avaló justamente
que la red no fuera más neutral y que
las grandes empresas distribuidoras de
internet tuvieran la posibilidad de
generar esto no el hecho de la
posibilidad de recortar si la gente no
pagaba o poder acceder a cierto tipo de
contenidos u otros no dependiendo de qué
está relacionado un poco como la equidad
de su acceso a los contenidos a los
contenidos de internet por ejemplo yo
pago menos entonces me puedo leer tal
matt y no puedo por ejemplo uno va a
tardar la velocidad a ser mucho menor y
voy a tardar en entrar a ver por ejemplo
si yo pago netflix el sistema y yo pago
menos o netflix no está dentro de las
grandes corporaciones entonces cuando yo
lo veo va a ser la calidad va a ser
menor va a tardar muchos más tiempo en
hacer el streaming o sea complicaciones
con respecto a la usabilidad del
internet por parte de la persona y eso
afecta a las empresas oa las a los
los individuos y a muchas empresas
también a las pequeñas empresas sobre
todo a las grandes empresas
de arreglos con los proveedores y los
consumidores y las pequeñas empresas no
entonces bueno en este caso los
senadores demócratas están tratando de
porque se terminaba el plazo fue en
febrero que se presentó esta nueva
moción para revocar lo que había
dispuesto a obama y tenían dos meses
para alegar y se está llegando al fin de
ese tiempo y los senadores demócratas
están empezando a en realidad han
juntado le falta una firma o sea
convencer a un republicano para que
firme para poder llevarlo nuevamente al
plano de la discusión y ver qué pasa en
definitiva si esto no sé si esto se
revoca gracias a los senadores y después
al paso de la cámara a la cámara alta
el presidente tan podría vetarlo
presidencial así que en realidad creo
que estamos a la espera de que eso pase
pero igualmente es importante saber que
se está trabajando para que esto
realmente no pase y que desean no tener
precedentes tampoco en el resto del
mundo y yo hablé con un romántico bueno
con el más romántico de los románticos
es romeo romeo de la de romeo y julieta
22 y capuletos de la gran de la gran
obra de william shakespeare que fue está
haciendo reinterpretada por la ópera de
montreal y es un tenor español que está
interpretando romeo entonces conversé
con este tenor español que ya he hecho
todos los papeles que todo cualquier
persona puede querer hacer siendo tenor
pero que en este caso está haciendo un
zoom es un sueño para cualquier tenor
interpretará romeo me explico como
cualquier persona que tiene ese timbre
de voz quiere interpretar este personaje
porque bueno es el más romántico es el
más reconocido es una de las historias
más más conocidas por todo el mundo
su nombre es ismael jordi español y el
vino
con el grupo que vino o estaba ahí parte
canadiense en una obra hay muchos
intérpretes canadienses
en concursos y lo digo así y además lo
que me decía él es que además él vive en
italia y denver o que eres vive en
verona opción nació para interpretar ssp
es etc entonces conversamos con ismael
jordi que está aquí en montar por
algunos meses durante la presentación y
el imau hermoso el buen montón de
permito sí muy bien leonora te permite
saber de joven y lo que me explicaba y
me parece interesantísimo es que este
rol de romeo es muy diferente porque el
pri el romeo del principio de la obra no
es el mismo romeo del final claro la
vida de romeo cambiabas ya no se puede
hacer con dos personajes no tiene que
hacerlo el mismo entonces él tiene que
ser obvio a mí al mismo tiempo maduro no
entonces tiene que en el dinamismo de un
chico de 15 años y además la madurez
y perdió a su amada entonces de 60 años
hace 15 años
entonces esos son los temas que les
presentamos esta semana vamos ahora a
leer rápidamente algunas cartas para
después de esta pequeña pausa le damos
entrada el castor citó
filete gene fue rápidamente algún
mensaje que tengan por ahí leonardo las
colombianas de gerardo ferro rojas y no
dije colombianas con otro día creo que
usted ya se mete donde la captura de
santrich negociador de las farc dice
esto demuestra que sigue siendo uno de
los delincuentes y quien se acuerdo de
paz es la mentira más grande de los
colombianos
eeuu ha retirado la visa muchos
políticos pero uribe sigue con ella no
ha podido demostrar la izquierda
colombiana que él es un bandido como sí
lo son ellos dice albeiro es quien nos
escribe y nos comenta esa lista
reportaje el prof a si éste es
aquí estamos con una reacción a carlos
alvarado elegido presidente de costa
rica esteban dice lo mejor que puedo
pasar fue que la gente saliera a votar
ahora esperar que pasara con una
asamblea y ahora esperar que pasara con
una asamblea tan dividida eso es un gran
problema si no hay acuerdos entre los
partidos ya que los más perjudicados
seremos nosotros los ciudadanos
quiero agregar también que los problemas
no son de este gobierno como se dijo
durante toda la campaña por parte del
partido rn y todos los demás ese
problema viene desde hace muchas
administraciones atrás y no han podido
hacer nada ahora les toca a todos juntos
trabajar por un solo objetivo costa rica
ojalá dios los ilumine para mejorar el
mejor país del mundo mi país y el de
ustedes que el trabajo que viene es
complicado pero es una responsabilidad
de todos ustedes los políticos en quien
confiamos un país y también de nosotros
como ciudadanos apoyar sus decisiones
siempre y cuando sea lo mejor para el
país dice esteban desde costa rica
muchas gracias a este valió nada y acá
tengo voy a voy a tomar tres comentarios
porque se refieren al mismo tema de un
neurólogo experto en epilepsia que
ofrece consultas gratis en español desde
saskatchewan escribe geomar stern que es
de ecuador
jessica ramos de guadalajara méjico y
georgina victoria garcía
carolina gudiel de guatemala de tres
países y finalmente explican sus
problemas de epilepsia que tienen ellas
o su familia y quieren consultar
entonces se hacen consultas esto acá eso
nosotros no podemos responder pero si en
entrevista con el médico y en el
reportaje está el link el enlace es el
enlace donde pueden van a entrar a la
universidad de saskatchewan y están tres
lenguas español inglés francés donde ahí
tienen todo explicado cómo hacer los
trámites para consultar gratuitamente a
este médico de esas capturas porque ha
tenido mucha gente a kutxa comentado
porque parece que es un tema que
preocupa mucho exactamente entonces
vayan al reportaje de nuevo en nuestra
página internet
si quieren buscarlo rápidamente en la
sección de búsqueda ponen neurólogo y va
a ser uno de los diversidad neurólogo
epilepsia y lo tienen exactamente y ahí
mismo encontrarán el en el enlace aquí
tengo mensajes sobre
la noticia el gps para localizar parejas
sexuales dice mira qué bien no tenía
idea que esto funcionará lo voy a probar
a ver qué pasa dice confesó fuente dura
eso se llama la persona en realidad hice
confesor ventura no pero no sé lo que me
llama la atención en lo sugestivo de su
correo electrónico es el naranjita 69 o
sea que el 69 se puede entender que
equipo ganó en la no es el año de la
naranja no sé
holanda se estaba preparando en el 69
para llegar al mundial de argentina 78 y
casi ganó el mundial
y no cumplió con las instrucciones de
los de los directores técnicos exacto
trofeo otro mensaje sí aquí uno y ha
cambiado este es un mensaje corto de
sobre el tema premisa mundial en canadá
se implanta glándula
tiroides en el brazo y este mensaje lo
envía vicenta josefina di giorgio ahora
dice soy vicente y tengo cientos de dos
kilos y no tengo la tiroides por un
cáncer y vivo con la vitro sin a ese día
por favor decidí hacerme la operación yo
soy de buenos aires argentina
agradecería su contestación gracias
vicente jose mayor de 61 años
chiquitito acá hay un comentario sobre
2015 el año en que los canadienses le
dijeron no a stephen harper y escribe
lázaro rosa y dice que bueno stephen
harper no tenía mucho amor hacia los
inmigrantes y que querían canadá sólo
para blancos pues se nos acabó el tiempo
así que vamos a hacer una pequeña breves
y sima pausa para despedirnos
buenos días mi nombre es el collage yo
soy director artístico de la ópera de
montreal y les invito a escuchar canadá
en las américas carrey de radio canadá
[Música]
y bueno se nos acabó el tiempo gracias a
esto a todos aquí en el estudio los
micros leonora chapman librero gimeno y
paloma martínez también agradecemos a
chantal sansó bar que está en los
controles técnicos y aplaudo el que
también hace un trabajo de conexión de
cables y de conexiones internet y otras
cosas así que muchas gracias a ambos les
damos cita el próximo viernes a la misma
hora por facebook live y este fin de
semana en nuestro sitio internet muchas
gracias por acompañarnos hasta la
próxima de dios los espías
[Música]